following his third phone call with
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu in just four days US President
Joe Biden denounced the recent hamus
attack on Israel as pure unate evil
Biden asked Congress to provide
additional military assistance on top of
the 3.8 billion the US sends annually
the White House confirms Munitions and
missile interceptors are on route to
Israel to replenish its Iron Dome rocket
Interceptor system and we will make sure
Israel has what it needs to take care of
its citizens defend itself and respond
to this
attack the US has also pledged
intelligence but won't provide soldiers
to support Israel's military it's also
not urging restraint as Biden compared
the actions of Hamas to the Islamic
State which murdered hostages starting
in 2014 in Syria and Iraq the brutality
of Hamas
these bloodthirstiness brings to mind
the worst the worst Rampages of
Isis this is
Terrorism the Biden Administration has
reiterated its commitment to a two-state
solution to resolve the Israeli
Palestinian conflict but Biden's speech
failed to offer support for Palestinian
civilians instead he claimed moral High
Ground between the United States and
Israel in comparison to Hamas
terrorists per purposely Target
civilians kill
them we uphold the laws of war a law of
War it matters there's a
difference but that's not true not
historically in past United States and
Israeli conflicts or now and in the case
of Israel its defense minister has
halted all electricity food and water to
Gaza for the foreseeable future elements
necessary to sustain civilian life
Kimberly hit Al jazer the White
House and Hamas have released a
statement in response to President
Biden's condemnation of the group they
say his comments constitute an attempt
to cover up the Israeli occupation
government's crimes and terrorism
against the Palestinian people and that
Biden's speech did not point to the
massacr committed by the Israeli
occupation of forces against the
Palestinian people let's bring in Ramy
curri he's a distinguished public policy
fellow at the American University of
Beirut he joins us live from Boston Ramy
always good to have you here uh look
there's already this war of narratives
in this conflict ever since uh the US
announced this unwavering support for
Israel we've heard Israeli officials
declare Palestinians as human animals
and proclaimed their intentions to
commit crimes uh Against Humanity how
worrying is this
narrative it is worrying uh it's been
going on for many many years uh it's
been one of the success stories of the
Zionist Israeli public relations uh and
lobbying campaigns in the United States
across all society and the media and the
movies education politics um and uh the
result is that the American president uh
the strongest man in the country who
influences the country more than anybody
else probably has come out in excessive
support of anything that Israel wants
it's quite extraordinary the intensity
and the scope of what Biden said and his
passion as he said it was also quite
unusual for him um and he basically
continued the process that has been
going on for decades since really since
the 1967 war um of of supporting Israel
militarily and economically and
protecting it diplomatically at the UN
and at the RCC and anywhere where Israel
may be held accountable the make sure
that doesn't happen uh the danger here
Ry let me just jump in here because
they're pushed for time I mean how is
this war and the narrative playing out
in the US media particularly as we are
already in the 2024 election cycle and
President Biden has an important
domestic audience to play
to it plays out very clearly by uh
having very very few Palestinian
authentic Palestinian voices a torrent
of Israeli voices officials former
ambassadors current officials um and an
intense Focus uh on the in the
mainstream media television is
particularly on the families in Israel
who have been worrying about their
children who they can't find they don't
know if they're dead or if they've been
taken prisoner and there's this really
tear-jerking uh short stories in the TV
about these families and they're very
powerful uh and there's they now do them
uh five six seven seven times a day you
see them almost on every American TV
station you don't see the equivalent
about Palestinians um and also you know
we know the names of the Israelis we
know the families in their living rooms
but we not know anything all we know
about Gaza is that Israelis are bombing
it in selfdefense and this has become a
very clear pattern uh that permeates not
just the media but also the public
political sphere at the national level
where Israel concentrates its uh its
lobbying and its and its pressure
campaigns which which have succeeded and
the last point now is that there the
Israelis with complicity by many
Americans are trying to silence the
voices of Palestinians or Pro
Palestinian Progressive Americans in
universities and labor unions and media
and other places and and this is now
being fought out in the courts Ramy we
know the US government is a signatory to
both the Geneva conventions and the
genocide convention which means it has
obligation under international law uh to
prevent war crimes is this a
responsibility that the US is failing to
shoulder do you
think yes the US and many other
countries Great Britain and many other
Western countries uh there's two things
here you have these individuals who are
politicians and politicians say whatever
they need to say to gain the public
support or financial backing of donors
or votes at that moment and the second
point is that these are especially when
you look at the US the UK and some other
countries these are Colonial Powers it's
not the old style colonialism of the
19th century it's colonialism where
these countries feel that what they say
how they act how they dress how they
behave their values should be the ones
that all the world follows and they set
the rules and everybody else should
follow they can break the rules if they
want but nobody else should break them
Ramy just a final quick thought to you I
mean many experts say this is not a
conflict that has a military solution
and in terms of preventing further loss
of Israeli and Palestinian lives The Way
Forward is to address the historical
source of this and that the US must end
what many see as complicity in Israeli
apartheid and the dehumanization of the
Palestinians so what is the way forward
just briefly
Remy there has to be a buildup of demand
to do this within the United States and
I've experienced this myself over the
last five decades that I've been in and
out of the us and the anti-vietnam war
movement the environmental movement the
women's rights movement the Civil Rights
Movement these took years and years and
years to develop enough popular
mobilization and support to force the
national leaders in Washington to change
their policy apartheid the Americans
didn't want to change the but they were
forced to in the end to go against
apartheid in South Africa so it'll take
time Ramy curri many thanks for your
thoughts and your analysis Ramy thank
you very much indeed